An average Thursday morning in my life as a 22 year old Chad wife.
I get up around 6:30 or 7,
and I first start by packing my husband's lunch
because he leaves her work around 7.
He's been up since, like, 5,
and he makes himself breakfast.
So I just, like,
get up, pack his lunch,
we cuddle a little bit.
So we don't see each other a lot these days.
When he can get the work,
he works for long hours,
so it's always nice when we see each other.
And then the next thing that I do is I go and sit down on the couch,
read my Bible,
do my devotions.
I'm enjoying morning and evening by Spurgeon right now.
And then I start getting ready for the day.
I do dry shampoo on my bangs,
water the cat, um,
and then I'm gonna put on a dress.
I love wearing dresses during the day.
I just feel so put together.
And then I fix my hair.
I've been loving this,
like, 90s style.
And then I'm gonna make my breakfast,
which is a protein shake pretty much every day.
But today I have some bagels that I made the day before.
So I'm having a bagel and cream cheese.
These are blueberry bagels.
Then I sit down
and I review my to do list and add a couple things to it.
And then I'm going to ship off some packages
for my customers over at My cottage shop.
And then today, I'm starting on my first project,
which is reorganizing my office.
Thanks for watching